what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into new 52 Batman well
technically it's called city of owls but
it's really called like nine of the owls
I think really in terms of how I sort of
look at it really it's like this great
big huge like 12 issues story arc more
or less that might even be closer to 13
um but it's really just kind of called
the court of owls storyline but it's
really kind of split into two things but
the fact remains that this video right
here will basically wrap up the court
any traditional sense but the cool thing
about this is that during the whole you
know revelation of the court of owls
Bruce Wayne had actually come across and
realized the basis behind de Grayson now
this was really a little bit of a
controversial thing and the reason for
this is because of the fact that dick
Grayson's history was pretty standard in
the sense that he was very much like
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne witnessed his
mother and father being killed by a guy
in an alleyway and it inspired him to
become Batman
Dick Grayson was much the same way he
was part of a trapeze group called the
flying Grayson's his parents were killed
and the result was that he was taken in
by Bruce Wayne and eventually desired
revenge allowing him to go forward as
Bruce Wayne's training the difference
here is that as Robin Dick Grayson was
like this incorruptible character where
Bruce was dark and Bruce was brooding
Dick Grayson always looked to the light
always looked at a better idea of how
things could be and for the most part
that was maintained to a degree you know
with regards to the new 52 he was still
relatively similar to that now of course
DC started messing around with his
courage a little bit making him a secret
agent you know bringing in agencies like
Spiral and different things like that
and that received kind of a lukewarm
reception some liked it some hated it
but with the really with the Nightwing
tie-in to the court of owls a court of
owls event what we ended up finding out
was that were traditionally Hayley
Circus was just a circus in actuality
they were functioning with a pact that
went alongside the court of owls and
what would happen if Hayley circus would
basically present us some of their most
outstanding you know acrobats or their
outstanding trapeze and those trapeze
would be used by the court of owls for
the purpose of eventually becoming the
talent now what just did is it expanded
on the talent mythos so it actually
introduced a guy by the name of William
Cobb now of course
DC try to expand on the role of the
talent it didn't really catch on and
nobody really cared that much and true
they just kind of view them as a
henchman and that was really about it
but the idea was that William Cobb was
one of a long line
of men who had played the role of the
talent just like the court of owls the
modern day you know iteration of the
court of owls was one of a long line of
groups who have been part of the court
of owls and the idea here was that the
court would basically poison the blood
stream of individuals with something
called Elektra my belief it was and what
would essentially happen is it would
permeate their cells so that when the
time came when that person died for
whatever reason whether it was old age
whether they were killed prematurely
whatever the case may be the court of
owls would take their body they would
basically bring them back to life with
something called Dionysian and then in
turn they would become a talent and that
was the intention for Dick Grayson that
did grayson was basically selected by
the court to be their newest talent once
William Cobb served his purpose it was
presumably dead whatever the case may be
and so what would happen is Dick Grayson
would basically live out his life you
know and whatever means he ended up
living it out and and then maybe he'll
die in a car wreck or maybe he'll die of
old age or ever the case may be but when
that happens he would be brought in by
the court of owls and then they would
basically make him into a talent and so
he would go forward basically as one of
their assassins of course it wouldn't
really be old age that would kill him I
mean you know they would have him killed
probably in the prime of his life just
to make sure that you didn't have like a
90 year old Dick Grayson running around
trying to assassinate people but
subtractor names here he's unwittingly
been selected as an assassin so again
that was kind of a huge revelation here
and so what that did is it really kind
of like double the efforts of Bruce
Wayne right because now you know Scott
Snyder and NBC had basically established
that it wasn't just a matter of oh I
need to stop the stoplight courthouse
now it was the court of owls aren't just
trying to seize control of Gotham City
they're turning the lives of people
upside down and so again it really kind
of doubled the efforts of Bruce Wayne
and his desire to take them out now of
course again when we in the last video
of the court of owls we had basically
picked up with the idea that the court
themselves have basically gone through
and said okay look you know if that man
is going to work against us and if we
cannot take control of the city by going
in and influencing candidates and
operating behind the scenes then we'll
take the city by force and so what they
did is they basically unleashed all of
their talents and symptom all throughout
Gotham City now this is when the comic
books of like Nightwing and I think that
girl had been published at the time and
Detective Comics and a few others
basically came in and covered a lot of
the nine of our stuff all that really
happened with the court with regard to
those real times that's why we have it
really covered them is because we're
focusing mostly on Batman
all that it really happened with those
tie-ins is the bat family had discovered
that the court looked to take out
certain individuals who were influential
in Gotham but stood against the court or
worked against it the goals and desires
of the court one of those people knew
about the court or not all the bat
family really did everybody outside of
Batman for the most part all they really
did was run around and save those people
who were on the hit list that was really
it I mean that was really the extent of
it it was interesting but is by no means
required reading for you know for the
whole court of owls story without with
Batman but with regards to Bruce himself
the court actually goes through and
really the talents just kind of descend
on Wayne Manor and immediately attack
him now this is kind of the important
thing here because what ends up
happening I really what we saw with
regards to you know the first court of
owls video that we did it so the court
themselves knew that Bruce Wayne was
Batman that was really one of the big
revelations because in the realm of DC
on the DC Universe one of the most
closely guarded secrets is the identity
of Batman the identity of Superman the
identity of Wonder Woman that's one of
the most closely guarded things they try
not to let the world know about that
just because of the fact that if people
knew that Clark Kent was Superman then
Lois Lane would be in jeopardy and you
know Perry would be in jeopardy and so
on and so forth you know Jimmy Olsen and
so on Bruce Wayne is the exact same way
they knew that Bruce Wayne was Batman
you could just literally tear down
everything that Bruce Wayne's built you
could launch a multitude of campaigns
against it now this one is a little more
tangible and it's really kind of Scott
Snyder bringing in the other half of
Batman's storytelling and that's why
it's so cool because historically
speaking whenever we read Batman stories
we expect to see a blend of detective
work and then fighting that's really one
of the things we like to see is Batman
just beating people up it's one of the
coolest things about his storytelling
you know how ruthless he can be
sometimes you know push the person to
the point where they genuinely believe
they're going to die but of course we
know Batman is not actually going to
kill them with regards to this tidbit
here the talons descending on Wayne
Manor proper is really just for the
purpose of taking out Bruce Wayne so of
course what he ends up doing is donning
this massive you know how that seemed
more or less and just taking it to town
on these towns I mean really just kind
of wrecking through every last one of
them because I'm truth despite the fact
that these guys are relatively undead
despite the fact that these guys you
know are pretty formidable in the end
they're not really able to take out
Bruce Wayne now of course the reason why
is because of the fact that Batman
realizes that these talents are able to
run around and there
able to do their own thing because
they're not frozen basically extremely
cold temperatures is the tool that's
used by the court to keep the talent and
stasis more or less and so that man's
realization you know of this information
is to essentially freeze all these guys
up to basically you know use a multitude
of different resources typically put
them back in stasis again by using very
cold temperatures and so of course this
in conjunction with unleashing its backs
on you know the various members of the
Talon you know really kind of wraps
things up pretty fast and so of course
once the temperature drops low enough
all these guys more or less just kind of
freeze and go back into stasis again and
that's really the end of them and so
what it does is it allows Batman to turn
his attention to the most logical target
of the court themselves Lincoln March
now here was a kind of cool thing about
these tie-ins the way the tie-ins took
place is they all happened basically in
a time frame which means it like at
seven o'clock this happens a nightly ad
you know eight o'clock this happens in
Detective Comics you know at nine
o'clock this happens in Batgirl the
problem with this is that you would
literally have to break the college down
page by page in order to cover it in
true chronological order otherwise you
end up reading Nightwing and then
halfway through that way you have to
stop and then read detective comics and
then like the quarter of the way to
detective comics you have to stop and
jump to Batgirl I think it's really kind
of weird the way it all comes together
and it really kind of threw things off
it was cool if you're going to assemble
it that way it makes it for a really
really interesting and cohesive story
but in terms of what we're trying to do
here it would confuse the hell out of
you guys so so we're not going to do
that we're really not going to do a
play-by-play like and then we switch
over to Nightwing at 7:32 p.m. like
we're not we're not going to we're not
going to do that instead Batman of
course travels to go see Lincoln March
now again in the last video we had
covered that that we had basically said
that Lincoln shared an identity shared
an affinity for Batman in terms of how
it is they viewed Gotham City and a lot
of this revelation came at the top of
Wayne tower you know the building that
was being constructed by Bruce Wayne it
was basically going to be this beacon of
hope for the city of Gotham and a beacon
to the world saying that Gotham is a
desirable place to live and it was a
really cool exchange between the two of
them because Lincoln March had told this
very interesting story to Bruce Wayne
about how Lincoln's mother had died and
the last thing that he had of her
possession was basically this mist shape
and heart-shaped pendant and it was kind
of cool to see this you know this
exchange between the two of them because
of the fact that it was a very human
moment for both it was basically
of them realizing that they have the
same goals and they had the same
ambitions at heart the problem with this
was that as Lincoln March had explained
he was directly working against the
court of owls because of the fact that
the court had basically warned link and
straying away from the path that you're
on move away from this road that you're
on because you're conflicting our
interests and we will kill you if you
don't and so again because of this with
Lincoln March effectively on his
deathbed it's almost like he's trying to
get revenge by passing the name of the
members of the court of owls directly to
Bruce Wayne himself and so what we do is
we transition to a group basically a
family that are called the powers family
this is really interesting because it's
basically composed of Joseph and his
wife Maria and the reason why this is
important is because it shows us that
when it comes to wealthy individuals
Bruce Wayne is not the only game in town
now for the most part we always kind of
figured that was the case right I mean
we always kind of figured that Bruce
Wayne wasn't like the only rich guy in
Gotham but there wasn't a whole lot of
expansion in terms of the really wealthy
in Gotham as far as normal people go we
would see them from time to time but
more often than not it would be like
two-face has a ton of money and he's
doing nefarious things would be like
penguin has a ton of money and he's
running a criminal empire something
along those lines and here's how he runs
into Batman this time that was really
yet that was really the only con find
there when it came to Scott Snyder
expanding on the Batman mythos it wasn't
just about creating a new group in
Gotham City or at least introducing a
group in Gotham City that Batman didn't
know about that have been operating for
hundreds of years it was bolstering that
it was basically grabbing other members
of Gotham's elite and saying what if
some of Gotham's you know wealthiest
people out there we're working against
Gotham proper and so again is kind of a
cool scenario because what it tells us
is that where Batman operates from the
shadows bringing down criminals there
are individuals who operate from the
shadows to conquer Gotham and that was
really what was going on with the
quarter valves the quarter bells
wouldn't necessarily intervene by you
know sitting an army into Gotham City
like they did with nine of the Owls
instead they would influence politicians
they would pay off judges they would do
different things either that or they
would snatch them up and they would drag
them to the labyrinth and say you can
spend the rest of your days in this
place until you go crazy and basically
you know kill yourself or you can do
what we tell you to do and the
alternative is to basically just walk
rank-and-file that's exactly what they
would do so the court of owls functioned
in a lot of different ways but of course
with Bruce Wayne being given
names of these individuals by Lincoln
March this highlights a very important
part of the story what this seems to
indicate from Scott Snyder is that
Batman never would have realized who
they were on their own they were too
well hidden
you know Joseph and Maria powers were
just too well hidden they were too far
hands off nobody would have known who
they were or that they were even
involved in the court of Alice now a lot
of the reason why this was the case was
simply because of the fact that the
powers family lived in more or less of
hen house in a building that nobody
could gain access to unless you were
personally invited that place was a
fortress the press was not allowed in
there the general public was not allowed
in there there's no indication that
Bruce Wayne ever saw the inside of that
they were very reclusive very shut off
now the indication of the question that
we were kind of have to ask here is well
then wouldn't that make them the most
logical people to be the court of owls
if they were so reclusive onto the first
ones that Bruce Wayne would think of yes
and no because you also have the thing
from himself Bruce Wayne's very
reclusive Bruce Wayne hides out in Wayne
Manor almost all day long now for him
it's because he's Batman because he's
fighting against crime different things
like that but no one knows what goes on
behind closed doors but seems to be
going on here is that when it comes to
the wealthy elite in Gotham it's pay you
leave me alone I leave you alone and
we'll just call it a day that really
seems to be what's happening here so of
course with Batman tracing down the
location of the courthouse after
essentially kind of interrogating Maria
powers what ends up happening here is
Alfred's of course basically says hey
look she's calling her husband your plan
to basically trace the location of her
husband worked the problem is that his
phone is in a blacked-out area so I can
only give you a few blocks but I can't
tell you exactly where it's located at
but this is when Scott Snyder is running
comes full circle when it's wet his
whole story comes back to full circle
again and the reason why is because in
the last video we had talked about how
after the death of Bruce Wayne's parents
he had investigated the court of owls
believing by the court were the ones
that were responsible for his parents
death that instead of killing his
parents directly they hired some you
know some loast low-level guy named Joe
Chill to have his parents killed and
then just make it look like a crime of
desperation when in reality you know
Bruce Lane believed the court of owls
were the ones who pulled it off what
descends up telling us is that where
Bruce Wayne originally went to harbor
house
believing the court of owls operated out
of there and found nothing the truth is
that he was right the entire time he was
right where he doubted himself where he
said no no
I went there and I poked around all the
clues led to this place being the court
of owls I guess I was wrong
this is Scott Snyder saying here's how
smart Bruce Wayne is he's always been
this smart he follows the clues he
listens to logic he listens to reason
and all the clues and all the signs
indicated that the court of owls
operated out of harbor house now this is
kind of cool because this is basically a
scenario where it essentially seems by
the court of owls themselves are not
keeping their tracks as clean as they
thought they would or maybe they were
relying on the intelligence of adults
who would consider some things to be
nonsensical and ignore them when in
reality that nonsensical thing is an
important clue to point to the location
of the court themselves and of course
when Bruce gets to the court proper he
basically finds that they're all dead I
mean every last one of them have been
dead you know they essentially drank
some kind of a substance and ended up
killing them all now of course this
seems to be like a ritualistic suicide
of sorts that they realize or at least
you know is alfred explains it to bruce
wayne that batman had basically taken
the city back you know batman now knew
about the court of owls and the court
themselves realize it was only a matter
of time before he brought them all down
and so they essentially just kind of
killed themselves so they wouldn't have
to wait for any measure of you know of a
trial you know being arrested or
anything along those lines and so again
the great thing about this is that Scott
Steiner gives every indication that this
is where the story ends he gives every
indication this is where it all stops
but it doesn't and that's why I love
this run so much because Binney takes
everything that we've seen so far and
flips it on its head and that's the
coolest thing the reason why is because
of the fact that Bruce Wayne is supposed
to have a meeting later on today and of
course Alfred is talking to about the
meeting what it's supposed to be
scheduled means to get ready and so on
and so forth but having a conversation
looking at a picture of Thomas and
Martha Wayne Batman takes off and it's
the coolest thing in the world and the
reason why is because he travels to the
morgue of where Lincoln March is
supposed to be and simply finds a note
that says follow me down the rabbit hole
now this is a universal sign in
literature ever since Alice in
Wonderland was written you know by Lewis
Carroll Alice in Wonderland tumbling
down the rabbit hole with absolutely no
idea what you're fine below has been a
literary metaphor for the idea of
walking down a path with no idea what's
there with the old basically walking
down in tunnel with a blindfold on and
it's really Scott's letter saying that
Batman is just following a trail of
breadcrumbs with no idea what's at the
other end
we end up doing is getting this little
bit of an explanation about a place
called the Willow Wood home for children
now to be honest this is creepy and it's
one of the creepiest things that I've
seen so far it's almost like that like
Waverly Hills Sanatorium or Santana or
whatever it is have you never had a
chance look it up it's this creepy place
in Louisville Kentucky and a buddy of
mine we're actually going to spend us
spend the night there on Halloween one
night but we decided not to because we
kind of figured that's the place that
you go to when you accidentally stumble
into a portal that leads you like to
another dimension that's basically hell
like we're not going we're not even
messing with that ghosts and monsters
and stuff like that not at all but this
is actually this is this is really kind
of creepy here and the reason why is
because of the fact that what we're told
is that the woodford home for children
was basically this place where kids with
mental disorders were taken but what
we're shown here are like like blood
prints and different things like that
and as is explained to us there was
basically a sinkhole that swallowed up
the orderlies quarters and what ended up
happening here is that because of the
fact that this place was so far removed
from Gotham City proper and because of
the fact that nobody ever checked on any
of the children here that when somebody
finally did come stumbling along they
basically found all the orderlies dead
and the kids just either starving to
death you know worse or dying of
dehydration walking around naked
absolutely disheveled you know and
living in their own filth and squalor I
mean it's a really really sad set of
circumstances but what this is designed
to do is feed into the sad nature of
Gotham City innocence the Gotham is
looked at by a lot of people as a broken
City
I mean it's broken and it's beyond hope
beyond redemption and should be allowed
to die just the traditional you know
line though the whole thought that we
saw from Batman Begins you know Gotham
City is a laboring beast gasping for
breath let the damned thing dot but of
course we know the Batman simply won't
let that happen and the idea is to
always try to breathe new life into it
and so again this really kind of hits
home at the nature of all that now of
course what we end up finding out is
that link in March as he had basically
you know kind of taunted Batman to come
to this location begins talking to him
about how you know who he really is
what he's really about and what we end
up finding out here is that it was
Lincoln Marg who basically led to the
deaths of all the members of the court
of owls you know he had simply Khoisan
to all of their drinks while they were
in their meeting they all died at the
same time Bruce Wayne it basically
recalls or you know really kind of
brings the reason up in terms of why he
took off in the first place and the
I was because of the story that Lincoln
March had given Bruce Wayne in Wayne and
Wayne Tower when Lincoln marcha talked
about how his mother had died and left
him you know this miss shapen heart
pendant and that kind of thing and Bruce
Wayne remembered that that was the exact
same pendant that Martha Wayne was
wearing in that picture and so the
implication seemed to be here that
Lincoln March was a false name that he
was basically grabbing little clues and
hints from the life of Bruce Wayne and
rolling the men to a cohesive story now
what Lincoln March does here is he
basically presents the scenario that he
himself is Bruce Wayne's brother the
reason being because of the fact that
while he does have that miss shapen
heart pendant those pendants are only
given to people who are from you are
basically children that live within the
school for homes and so for Lincoln
March is essentially saying here that
Martha Wayne is his mother and he's
basically the brother that Bruce Wayne
never knew about now one of the crazy
things about this is that for a lot of
people the inning of this story seemed
to be an instance where Scott Snyder
kind of wrote himself into a corner and
didn't quite know how to get out again
but the great thing about this and
really one of the reasons why I loved
this is because of the fact that it's
designed to kind of ask all these
what-if questions about Bruce Wayne
remember the entirety of the court of
owls is designed for the purpose of
bringing in the possibility that Bruce
Wayne does not know as much about Gotham
as he thought he did I mean he claims to
know the streets inside and out he
claims to know the buildings inside and
out he claims to know the people inside
and out but he didn't know the powers
and other other members of Gotham's
wealthiest the court of owls he didn't
know the court of owls was there this is
another instance where Scott Snyder's
basically hitting home with the idea
that maybe this guy Lincoln March is
actually Thomas Wayne jr. maybe he is
the legitimate son of Thomas and Martha
Wayne and Bruce just never knew about it
the entire time now again from here this
really just kind of descends down into
into an exercise in traditional
comic-book battling in the sense that
you basically just kind of have burst
lane running against a Thomas Wayne
junior and that's really about it now of
course the conflict leads directly to
Wayne tower proper and the whole idea
here of Lincoln March is to essentially
I guess of Thomas Wayne this is
basically bring the tower down around
Bruce and the reason why is because this
fits in to the entirety of the narrative
as is given to us by you know Thomas
Wayne what he basically says here at
least what both
he says and what Bruce Wayne deduces is
that Thomas Wayne was presumably left
with in myth you know that home for
children by the lanes to keep him hidden
away from the world the result was that
they had Bruce Wayne himself and Bruce
Wayne became the rightful heir of the
Wayne family while this was going on
because of the fact that how much was
basically abandoned and left behind he
was adopted by the court of owls and
then brought in and raised by the court
and so the idea was that he basically
showed up as Gotham City's Savior when
in reality he was just a puppet of the
court of owls and so what ended up
happening here is that when he was
presumably killed by one of the talons
when Bruce Wayne stumbled in and Thomas
Wayne operating as Lincoln March gave
loose weighing the names of the members
of the court in truth he had actually
ingested that's very serum those talons
use in order to keep them alive and the
more or less kind of resurrected himself
so to speak and so the idea here was
that if he was going to basically
replace Bruce Wayne he was going to kill
off Bruce Wayne and carry on the memory
of Bruce by operating as the city's
mayor you know or one of his most
contributing members and he's going to
do exactly that
by killing Bruce Wayne and then
effectively taking his place Oh Bruce
Wayne you know Bruce Wayne passed away
but I'm his brother Thomas Wayne jr.
here's the documentation to prove it so
on and so forth now of course Bruce
basically uses the hubris of Thomas
Wayne when Thomas Wayne begins
detonating the various bombs of use
planted in Wayne tower to bring it all
down Bruce Wayne manages to make his
escape and so what Scott Snyder does is
he leaves everything ambiguous he leaves
it with the idea the Thomas Wayne jr.
basically survived now we know that by
way of the story Batman eternal which
I'm not really sure if we're going to
cover that or not but we know that
Thomas Wayne survived and he ends up
coming back what Scott Steiner did with
him there was kind of interesting but I
wouldn't say nearly as prevalent as his
role here in the court of owls storyline
but of course in the midst of all that
see how that man's basically visited
that kind of thing and the crazy thing
about this is that the conversation
between the two of them indicates that
Bruce actually believes that Thomas
Wayne jr. might really exist now of
course he goes through the paperwork and
begins looking at the history of the
Wayne's of Thomas and Martha Wayne
everything that they had done and what
he ends up fighting out here is that
indeed he did actually have a brother
who only lived for one night he was
basically born under the rest the child
was hooked up to an incubator and died
within 12 hours
but the question cannot be helped but
ask what if it was all a cover what if
Thomas and Martha Wayne gave birth to a
son and
and we're told well you know your son
has complications which they witness
those complications and the doctor you
know under orders from the court of owls
told Thomas and Martha Wayne I'm sorry
your child has passed away there's
nothing we can do
the child was effectively brought back
or taken by the court raised by the
court and then became Lincoln March all
the while being told you are Thomas
Wayne jr. you are the rightful son of
Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne you're the
rightful heir to the Wayne fortune and
the Wayne family Bruce Wayne can't help
but wonder is any of that true and Scott
Snyder asks us that question do you
think it's true do you really believe
that Bruce Wayne actually has a brother
named Thomas the issue with this is that
we're never given a definitive answer in
a story we're never told for any real
measure of certainty instead the mystery
is just kind of out there the question
is just kind of there and again it all
really kind of feeds back into this
notion that Bruce Wayne does not know
Gotham City as well as he thinks he does
now again this all feeds back into the
whole notion or I guess the whole idea
that Bruce Wayne himself is still
relatively new to the role of Batman you
remember when the new 52 first started
it's only been five years since Bruce
Wayne put on his cloak and cowl for the
very first time and became Batman so he
doesn't really know Gotham as well as we
would think he would know in the classic
Batman stories before the new 52 but the
fact remains here you know again this is
just kind of a a stir you know things to
come that are later on down the line
with regards to the Batman mythos but if
you are new here to come as explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like if you want to
see more videos about stories from the
new 52 that lead into the launch of DC
rebirth let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]
you